i think we should bow our heads in a
moment of silence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you hear that oh
it's a person
[Music]
[Applause]
please mr janitor if you just look over
here for two seconds i'll do anything
hey i'll watch a foreign film i'll talk
to a man with a ponytail
oh he's gone ron he's gone
you never had any kids right leslie no
you've got a great oven okay
time to go got ample room in there
honestly if you wanted to
you could go triplets right off the bat
leslie you got a big
industrial sized oven so we're done
right
there's your healthy baby oh wow
oh and there's another one
the baby has two bodies twins
ben we're having twins
no you're not cause look who's hiding
over here
triplets
triplets and here's a fourth i'm so
sorry no it's a little fleck of cream
cheese on the screen
just triplets wow you guys really dodged
a bullet can you imagine raising four
children at one time
a nightmare
triplets
triplets
tim lautner who owns the sawmill out on
lowell drive is a personal friend when
people in pawnee use the water fountain
they put their mouths completely over
the spouts it's like this weird
disgusting local quirk kiss one water
fountain drinker you're kissing everyone
in pawnee
including him
ron did you get my texts no
did you get my emails
did you see that i paged you
i i did not did you check your voicemail
i didn't we have a criminal emergency in
our hands someone planted a gateway drug
in the community garden
okay call the cops that'll lead to the
press then there'll be an investigation
and they'll find my fingerprints on the
manure and then we'll lose our funding
you don't have funding and we never will
if this gets out look i will call the
cops but just give me one day to deal
with this internally okay
sure
thank you and listen
if this thing blows up
i was never here
okay guys you know what i would love i'd
love if anybody just said something
positive
about oh i don't know anything i agree
let's just relax smoke another j and all
calm down another by the way it's
ridiculous that pot is illegal it grows
in the ground i've planted marijuana and
community gardens all over the city and
hasn't hurt anyone what you know michael
you are one pot loving
mother
pain and director okay stop it
um
where you go
drink up cause it has every herb and my
herb belt oh
tastes like a belt i know isn't it awful
but it works wonderfully so
tell me
do you admit that you're depressed
how did you know i didn't even know the
letters sticklio t-shirt the unshaven
face the doc martens and your hair does
not have that normal uptight rigid and
flexible and wide sense of fun
[Applause]
[Music]
can you please state your name for the
committee
gary gergich oh god jerry you can't even
get your own name right actually my real
name is gary
gary on my first day here the old
director he called me jerry and i just
didn't think i should correct him that's
ridiculous your name is jerry well
legally
my name is gary gary gergich
jerry gergich gary gergich jerry gergich
gary gergich jerry god they're both
horrible but jerry's better i'm gonna
call you jerry
okay jerry i have been here well 30-some
years
and the best way to cope with this job
is to do everything the exact same way
every day
heck i still use my original id card
from my first day on the job check this
out
oh my god
i gotta go put my sammy in the fridge
there's a drunk stuck in the slide
sir this this is a children's slide
you're not allowed to sleep in here you
know when i first tell people that i
work in the government they say oh the
government the government stinks the
lines are too long of the dmv but now
things have changed people need our help
and it feels good to be needed could you
put your arms to your side
and that might help you slide down a
little easier you know do you want to
come this way oh oh okay we're gonna
need you to get out go away get out of
the slide okay here we go okay please go
away okay wake up here we go out of the
slide you know government isn't just a
boys club anymore
women are
everywhere it's a great time to be a
woman in politics hillary clinton sarah
palin
me
nancy pelosi we did it
april ron we need to celebrate
everything that we've done together as a
group this is our last day here who
knows when we'll all be together like
this again
excuse me hi there's a swing in a park
near my house that's been broken for
about three months is it possible to get
that fixed anything is possible if you
follow your dreams
johnny karate accept getting a swing fix
none of us actually work here anymore
come back in two hours when the office
is open thank you
wait
actually sir we can help
we can and we will
because when we used to work here
helping people was our job
okay rain check that all right
they're here
i know i've been acting really weird
lately and um
i really like you what i'm about to say
is going to contradict the idea that i
really like you but that's what just
open the box please stop breaking out
the box okay leslie you're being really
nice and what i'm about to say is gonna
make you hate me okay then i'll just
open the box for you
wow
you knew
i figured it out a while ago i got you
something
let me open it for you
you have to go to washington hey hey
you know you were coming back here oh
what are you doing
oh my god what are you doing
i'm thinking about my
future i am deeply
ridiculously in love with you and above
everything else i just
i want to be with you
you